hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're in
round number nine of the 2018 candidates
tournament whenever this tournament does
go on to face magnus carlsen in november
for the world championships we do have
six rounds left of play so quite a bit
of chess still to determine the winner
our competitors today white's going to
be played by sergey cardiac and he is
the winner of the last candidates
tournament so he knows a thing or two
about winning this thing and what it
takes to have some momentum going into
the last five rounds after today his
opponent vladimir kramnik who just
played a marathon
yesterday did not come out on top of the
these players faced off in round two
they did have a draw
and pretty much this is their last
chance they're tied coming into this
round so uh the winner will definitely
have a chance to go on and compete for
the title uh the loser for the most part
will be out of contention unless there
is a miracle
so we'll go ahead and get started sergey
starts out pawn two c4
pawnee six knight c3
pawn d5 pawn d4 and then after knight to
f6 we have the queen's gambit
the exchange variation and usually in
the exchange variation the knight's
gonna be here on f3
white has decided to bring his knight to
c3 in development uh so after the knight
recaptures pioneer to e4
knight takes on c3 pawn up to c3 we do
have white with a strong advantage in
the center of the board
with his pawns and then black just
looking uh to
just chip away the counter-attack uh in
the center so starts out with pawn two
c5 not really expecting uh the pawn to
take here queens would come off the
board the bishop could then take here on
c5 that would give black a huge momentum
boost instead we see rook to be one
controlling this semi-open file uh so
that you know this light square bishop
cannot really move anywhere it's usually
not going to with the pawn here on e6
but just uh threatening you know his
opponents bishop d7 getting ready to
castle on the king side knights here to
f3 preparing the way if it wants to
bring his bishop here to
c4 b5 even check uh his opponent and
then castle on the king side kes on the
king side for black and here's where
things get interesting we see pawn two
h4
i don't think anyone was expecting this
this is not a
a book line by any means uh this is a
novel move by cardiacan and just saying
yeah uh
i i can still castle on the king's side
but i'm gonna be pretty aggressive here
and start to push up on the kingside
with my pawn h4 so we see pawn takes on
d4
pawn recaptures knight to c6 so just
development move attacking the center
and then pawn to h5 so
wow completely all in on the strategy to
attack and now doesn't even look like
white's looking to castle on the king
side which is somewhat odd it does have
a strong attack center control here
usually we're going to see white
castling have some sort of protection
and just milk his advantage in the
center of the board that's not what
we're seeing at all white's going on the
complete offensive mode here not just in
the center but on the king side
pawn to f5 uh so
vladimir saying yeah i need to do
something and counter it to actually
plays pawn to f5 after the pawn takes
queen down here a5 check bishop d2 not
too many great options as far as how to
defend this so bishop to d2 queen over
here to f5 uh bishop to c3 defending
this pawn here on d4 then pawn to h6 had
different options could have played
queen to e4 if he wanted to stay
aggressive but instead plays pawn to h6
now bishop to d3 attacking the queen
queen comes down here to a g4 attacking
the pawn here on g2 king to f1 so now
signaling for sure there's no way to
castle now does want to protect this
pawn here on g2
punt e5 saying you want to exchange
white says no trade skis today my friend
i'm going to have a pass pawn here that
you're going to have to deal with the
rest of the game pawn pushing forward
here to d5
pawn to e4
forking both the bishop and the knight
here offering up a trade since this
knight uh here on c6 is under fire so
pawn takes on c6 pawn recaptures pawn
takes here on f3 uh and this is where
things get pretty interesting
makes a lot of sense to just
take with the queen but black decides to
take with his rook if he does take with
his queen uh then we could see
queen take here rook recapture now king
up here to e2 to protect his bishop uh
maybe black decides to exchange you know
completely up to him bishop down here to
uh f5 king moves and then uh he could
take the the rook if he wants to on b1
could take the pawn uh and
then later worry about the rook he does
have some options but i feel like this
is a better play for black
after the rook comes down to f3
then we see bishop to
e2 now he did also have the option of
taking here on a b7 but it's extremely
complicated if we look at and see rook
takes here on f2 king takes
this king is wide open no protection we
have these two bishops we have the queen
here that can just start attacking his
opponent bishop down here h4 check uh
even if the rook takes queen h4 check
and then just gonna be dancing all over
the place very very difficult you know
for white to calculate every position
and say am i am i winning here yes you
know pawn takes on b7 and it's protected
by this rook so i'm gonna win one of
these pieces but in the meantime am i
gonna lose the game so while you know if
you were to just run this analysis yes
you could probably see that the pawn
taking on b7
looks better it's just no way to really
play that and feel safe about so it
plays the move that is is much more
objectively easier to see that it's
better and that's bishop to e2 attacking
both the rook and the queen behind this
knowing that the rook can't move here
and so black decides yeah i'm gonna go
ahead and give up my rook i'm gonna get
these two pawns pawn here on c6 and f2
in exchange for my rook not def that's a
pretty bad exchange as you can imagine
for black but rook takes on f2 check the
king takes the bishop down here to c5
king to f1 had the ashman as well to
king uh to e1 you just rarely see
white playing a strategy where he has no
defenders from a pawn perspective in
front of his king it's wide open for
black to attack but it's very difficult
to find
a strong attack uh that's gonna lead to
anything uh significant in the game
queen two f4 bishop up here f3 and now
the pawn takes on a c6 to get those two
pawns in exchange for that rook not not
necessarily the exchange he was looking
for but nonetheless uh white continues
with bishop down here to e1 bishop to e6
centralizing bishop to h4 rook over here
to f8 doubling up on this bishop on f3
so the king comes to g2 one wants to get
out of uh this line of fire also wants
to add a defender to the square here on
f3 vladimir decides now to play king to
h8 not really sure this does anything
almost feels like a wasted move to me
but rook to c1 attacking the bishop rook
down here to f5 rook up to c3
rook to
d5 which is another interesting move
giving up another rook since the bishop
can just take this and that's exactly
how bishop takes bishop takes here on d5
is opening up the door
for a strong attack for his bishop pair
and he can win back some material here
if he wants to but giving up two rooks
is somewhat weird but then we have the
great move and that's rook to f3 i guess
he just thought his bishop would take
here and then all of a sudden the king
would move he would capture this rook
here on h1 but f3 is a is a great move
uh it says yeah if you want to take
that's fine uh but the exchange for me
is going to be much better you know if
the bishop were to take then just queen
takes here on f3 uh you know you don't
want to see another exchange right here
because that's gonna be extremely bad
for black all of a sudden he has to
worry about a bishop in rook uh and just
gonna be gobbling up all these pawns
easy win for white if instead after the
queen takes queen down here to d2 check
yes you can gobble up that pawn here on
a two but at the end of the day white's
gonna have too much material this rook
is gonna do a ton of work in combination
with this queen uh white should have a
very very easy victory from here if the
bishop doesn't take if instead the queen
takes here on f3 then after the queen
takes you gotta take the queen back
bishop takes king recaptures we're in a
similar position as we saw before but
even now uh the king is in a more uh
prominent position to get to the center
start attacking his opponent rook can
easily get involved so all in all yes
this rook 2 f3 is stopping the attack
but there's no way for black to really
worry about and take that material right
now so he plays queen to a g4 bishop to
a g3 stopping the check a bishop up here
to d6 so rook to h3
you know playing defense right now but
white's up so much material he can do
that bishop to e7 queen to e2 says i'm
just not too worried you can take my
rook if you want to i can trade down a
little bit and still be well ahead of my
opponent queen 2 f2
pawn a5 pawn to a4 just stopping any
sort of threats coming down pawn to c5
so there's a pass pawn that's really the
only thing that white has to deal with
rook here to h1 bishop f6 rook over here
to e1 attacking the bishop bishop comes
back here to c6
rook 2 e3 just doubling up the rooks
here on the third ring so if it ever
comes down this pawn
to c3
both of these rooks if they want can go
ahead and take here exchange a rook for
a pawn and a bishop that's going to be a
good trade for white
queen 2 e2 attacking the pawn as well
queen back to h5 and then we see the
queen take on c4 pretty much all the
threats have now gone for black has
nothing going for him uh bishop back
here to d7 after rook to d3 of vladimir
kromak decides you know what i played a
91 move game yesterday i'm going to
shave off 50 moves today and just resign
so back-to-back losses for him it was
looking like he was in striking distance
of the leaders just a couple games ago
now all of a sudden after picking up
zero points in two games uh he's now
fallen well behind the leaders does not
look like he will be in contention to
win the candidates tournament sergey
kedakini he's not too far back
definitely is going to have to beat
fabiano and some of the other leaders to
have a chance but with five games left
he is now in contention after a great
game
today against his fellow countrymen so
congratulations to karjakin in round
number nine thank you guys for watching
so much much shorter game today than
yesterday which is uh
good from a coverage standpoint but
thank you guys so much for watching i'll
see you in the next video